we've got 24 triangle things right over
here and what i want to do in this video
is to divide it into different numbers
of groups so the first thing i want to
do is i want to divide this 24 triangle
things i want to divide it into three
groups and think about how many do i end
up per group
so let's try that out so i'm going to
divide into three equal groups so that
is one equal group
right over there
then i have another equal group
right over here
and then i have a third equal group
right over here so if i divide 24 into
three equal groups one two three how
many are going to be in each group well
we can count that we have 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 in each group so we could say
that 24 divided by 3
is equal to eight
now you might say hey this is very
similar to what we saw in multiplication
in multiplication we said if we have
three groups of eight we could view that
as three times eight and get twenty four
and you are exactly right we could also
write
3 let me do those same colors we could
also write that 3
times 8 so if i have 3 groups of 8
3 groups of 8 that that is going to be
equal to
that is going to be equal to 24.
so we started in this video we had 24
things we want to divide it into three
equal groups we got eight in each group
or you could say 3 equal groups of 8 is
equal to 24 but there's even other ways
of thinking about this so let me clear
this up a little bit
so let me clear that
we could also view so in the first
example i've viewed 25 i divided 24 into
three equal groups but you could also
view 24 divided by 3 as dividing 24 into
groups of 3. so let's think about what
that looks like so if we divide it into
groups of three
then for example
this is a group of three
that is a group of three
this is a group of three you might see
where this is going that's a group of
three
that is another group of three and we're
gonna think about how many groups of
three we're actually going to get so
this is another group of three
and that's
another group of three so how many
groups of three did we get well see we
have one two three four five six seven
eight groups of three so another way of
viewing 28 sorry the other way of
viewing 24 divided by 3 is divide 24
into groups of 3 and then you will have
8 groups of 3. and one way of thinking
about this if you want to express the
same the same thing in terms of
multiplication is if you have eight
groups of three
if you have eight groups of three that
is also going to be equal to twenty-four
whether you have four groups
whether you have three groups of eight
or eight groups of three either way
you're going to have 24.
now let's make things more interesting
what i want you to think about
is what is based on what we just saw
what is 24
what is 24
divided by
12. and i encourage you to pause the
video draw out 24 triangles like this
and try to and try to figure out what 24
divided by 12 is well i assume you've
paused the video and there's two ways to
think about 24 divided by 12. you could
say well let's divide 24 into
groups of 12 and think about how many
groups we have so we could do that so
let's see this is this is one group of
12 right over here
that's one group of 12 and then here is
another group of 12.
it's another group of 12. so how many
groups of 12 do we have
well we have two groups of 12 so we
could say 24 divided by 12
is 2 but another com just as reasonable
way of doing this is you could have said
you could have said well let me divide
24
into 12 groups instead of groups of 12.
so if i want to divide into 12 groups 12
equal groups well let's see this is one
equal group
two
equal groups actually let me do it this
way well let me do this yet two equal
groups 3
12. so once again if you say well i'm
going to divide 24 into 12 equal groups
how many do you have in each group well
you have two so once again 24 could be
viewed as 24 divided into 12 equal
groups and how many you have in each
group or 24 divided into groups of 12
and how many groups would you have and
that's what we saw in the in the last
example
so now let's make things even more
interesting
what i want you to think about
a couple of things i want you to think
about what 24
what 24 divided by
let's say divided by
sixes and i also want you to figure out
what 24
what 24 divided by let me use the same
color
divided by four is
divided by fours and once again i
encourage you to pause the video draw
these triangles and figure it out what
is 24 divided by 6 and 24 divided by 4.
so let's tackle 24 divided by 6 first
and i'll view this as let's try to group
let's try to divide 24 into six equal
groups
six equal groups so let's see this could
be one equal group
one equal group
two equal groups in fact each group here
is a group of four and we have six rows
so three equal group are three equal
groups four
five
and six
and so if you divide 24 into six equal
groups how many do you have in each
group well it's pretty clear you have
four
you have four in each group another way
we could have thought about that another
way we could have thought about that
is we could have said
we could have said what is how what let
me divide 24 into groups of six so if
you divided 24 into groups of six you
could have viewed it
like this
so that's one group of six
that's one group of six right there
that's another group of six
right over here
it's another group of six and i think
you see how many groups of six we have
how many groups of six we have we have
four
we have four
groups of six
four groups of six
well now let's think about what 24
divided by four is
well if i divide if i think if i view 24
divided by 4 is taking 24 and dividing
it into four equal groups i've just
drawn that i have four equal groups and
in each group i have six
in each group i have six so notice 24
divided by 6 is 4 24 divided by 4 is 6
and that's because i could view this as
4 groups of 6 or say that 4 times
4 times 6
4 times 6 is equal to 24
is equal to 24
or you could just as equivalently say
that 6 times 4 is 24.
you could equivalently say that 6 times
4
is equal to
24.